never saw  any one of my clinical clients  ever get away with anything  even once  and you think well people get away with  things all the time it's like no they  don't  they might  gain  a narrow advantage  in one dimension in the short term let's  say that you you're you use deceit your  business practices first of all that  doesn't work very well because people  will figure you out so as a long term  as a long term strategy it's terrible it  just doesn't work no one is going to  play with you if you're a cheat someone  asks what about these dictators that all  the power stalin's a perfectly good  example it's like  didn't he win  well  everyone stalin ever talked to lied to  him because they were absolutely bloody  terrified of him his country was a  nightmare  it was a hell and did he rule  yes but he ruled hell and if you think  that's a victory well go ahead and try  it see how much of a victory